كريستوفر هاردينغ هو رجل
أعمال يمتلك فريق كرة القدم الذي يمتلك منتجعًا
يُدعى Hodges Bay في أنتيغوا وقد
لاحظت على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي أن الناس كانوا
يسافرون إلى منتجعه ويعودون
مع الحيوانات لمساعدتهم في العثور على Better
Homes هنا في الولايات المتحدة لذلك هو
تحدث إليّ عن مصدر إلهامه
لذلك ، ولا يقتصر الأمر على
أنتيغوا فقط ، فاستمع
لذلك بدأنا برنامجًا تجريبيًا في
خليج هودجز في أنتيغوا وهو نوع من
نهج ثلاثي المحاور في الوقت الحالي
للبرنامج التجريبي للحيوانات الأليفة رقم واحد
عند تسجيل الخروج من الفندق إذا كنت
ترغب في جمع فاتورتك ، فإن 100 من هذه
العائدات ستخصص لمساعدة الكلاب
والقطط في أنتيغوا على إعادة هذه الحيوانات الأليفة إلى
منازلها ونقلها إلى Animal Haven في نيويورك
وأماكن أخرى حول الولايات المتحدة
تنص على أنه رقم واحد لدينا برنامج رفيق السفر
الذي يسمح للضيوف في الفندق
عند عودتهم إلى الولايات
بأخذ أحد الحيوانات
إلى أي مكان يذهبون إليه والمساعدة في
إعادة هذا الحيوان إلى المنزل
أه ثم رقم ثلاثة ، إنه حقًا
المفضل لدي ، وقد لا ترى
لماذا يمكن أن يكون هذا شيئًا للمساعدة ولكن
لدينا تواريخ لعب الجرو على
الشاطئ ولذا يتم إحضار كلاب صغيرة كل يوم سبت
إلى الشاطئ حيث
يمكن لضيوفنا التفاعل مع هؤلاء  الجراء وما
يفعله ذلك بالنسبة لهم يساعدهم
على التواصل الاجتماعي يجعلهم يتأقلمون مع
كونهم حول البشر الآخرين وهو
حقًا يجعلهم مستعدين
لفصلهم التالي من حياتهم عندما يتم
إعادة توطينهم في الولايات المتحدة الآن
أيضًا
ليس جزءًا  من البرنامج تضمن مثل
المشاهير والمؤثرين أيضًا
استعادة هذه الحيوانات ، أنا محق ، لقد
رأيت هذا بالتأكيد على Instagram ، نعم
بالتأكيد أعني أنه لا يهم إذا كنت
مؤثرًا أو مجرد
إنسان عادي يحب الجميع
لمساعدة الحيوانات في معظم الأحيان ،
ومع المزيد من المشاهير ومتابعي Instagram
الذين يمكننا النزول في
خليج هودجز ويرون الموقف الذي يرون
أنه يمكنهم فعلاً المساعدة ويمكنهم نقل
استرجع هذه الحيوانات مرة
أخرى والأهم من ذلك أن تنشر الرسالة على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الخاصة بهم ، أه فقط
سيساعد البرنامج على النمو ومساعدة المزيد
والمزيد من الحيوانات بينما نمضي قدمًا
سوزان كريستوفر ، فهو يعيش أيضًا جزءًا من
وقته في بورتوريكو وهو  عند القيام
بذلك هناك بشكل أساسي ، يمكنك الذهاب إلى
منتجعه وإحضار أحد هذه
الحيوانات مرة أخرى على متن الطائرة معك أه
لديهم تلك الشراكة مع Animal
Haven في نيويورك
، ثم يساعدون في إعادة هذه
الحيوانات التي نزحت بسبب
كارثة طبيعية ولم
يعد لديهم مالكها بعد الآن ،
فأنت تعلم أنها مجرد
مهمة رائعة ، وإذا كنت تريد معرفة المزيد
عنها ، فيمكنك الانتقال إلى
globalempowermentmission.org ،
طار الخط المائل العكسي إلى الحظيرة لمعرفة ومعرفة كيف
يمكنك المساعدة  أيضاً